make sure you pack their snacks and also
their little favorite toys that that we
can distract me so they can take a
pretty photo but you want to make sure
they're comfortable don't put them in
something that they wouldn't ordinarily
wear tights or sometimes uncomfortable
for little girls shoes that they
wouldn't normally wear I think the best
advice is to just designate one person
to be getting their kids attention
whether it's a family member or whether
you want the photographer to do it I
want to make sure that your kids have a
relationship with Santa prior to
actually like coming here whether it be
seeing them on on movies or even just
visiting like a mall where you might see
a Santa like out in the open you know
Salvation Army they have Santas outside
and stuff like that if kids see them and
it's normalized it makes it a little bit
easier and a little bit more comfortable
I think just let the moments be
authentic and try to have fun with it
really just to have fun having fun
because if you have that serious energy
kids can get a little bit scared
navigate
the most effective thing I've seen is to
start talking about what they're going
to get for Christmas each of the
different photographers has different
like
items and things that they try to
utilize to get the kids to like kind of
come down to earth so to speak we have
like a stuffed elf and we do have props
like we have presents around the trees
the thing that causes the Meltdown to go
poorly is when you say that if they act
like that Santa Won't give them what
they want for Christmas because then
he's the bad guy in some situations
where we'll kind of have the parent go
in there even if they're not intending
to take a photo and take a couple of
photos with them and get really close to
Santa just so they can know that Santa
is not a uh an enemy so to speak
sometimes like if kids do start crying
like the little ones really little ones
and parents still find that it makes the
best photos because it's really humorous
I I think some of the greatest Santa
photos of all time are when the kid is
crying or doing something silly and I
think those are the things that later
you cherish and so I I would say relax
have fun it's all about the the child's
experience